[Musique]
tout a commencé par la lecture d'un
courrier électronique que m'adresser un
matin en l'ami akira mizubayashi
professeur de littérature française à
tokyo
cheikh malek pourquoi ce besoin
impérieux de contact avec l'eau c'est là
la question de ce premier bain tu as
peut être éprouvé le besoin de revenir à
travers les gestes des baigneurs à une
couche oubliés de notre vie où se
révèlerait les rapports pour que notre
score entretien avec la réalité
matérielle du monde sensible
un peu comme une réponse j'ai entrepris
ce voyage à la rencontre d'amis
passionnés des plaisirs doux à nous
chaudronnier d'un sauna à helsinki
g bâle
propriétaire d'un hammam à istanbul
et la slovaquie dj et organisateur de
soirées dans les termes à budapest au
produit quant à moi je suis heureux de
t'accueillir à tokyo à la maison toi qui
a décidé de partir à la découverte des
vins de ce monde qu'on dit si flottants
car soumis à l'accidentel à l'éruption
d'événements
aux aléas du devenir des choses
terrestres
[Musique]
tél
quand nous sommes comme à nantes au
moyen-âge
c'est un moment agréable où une jolie de
la chaleur de l'eau je la sens se
propager et ses progrès sivement donc
toute la céline de mon corps me magatte
lô raté je reste ainsi de 10 à 15
minutes à me réchauffer ou jetaient
japon classe du beau foot est donc à la
da'wa data mais
je ne sors de l'eau que lorsque j'ai eu
chaud au point de sentir la
transpiration sur mon front
alors je m'assieds sur le dallage et je
commence en nous ça venait afin de me
laver pour de bon
dès lors je me retournais me réfugier
dans la chaleur de l'eau et j'y reste
qui gomme la première fois une bonne
dizaine de minutes
pour moi c'est le moment du plus grand
déplacement la plaie profonde et
puissante aux clients
[Musique]
bon ben pourtant touche à sa fin
sortant de la baignoire je remets les
planches est rectangulaire c'est de
façon à ce que l'eau reste chaude autant
que possible pour la personne suivante
cocotiers aux idées je me rince une
dernière fois avec l'eau qu'on appelle à
galliot lieu qui veut dire yves show de
finale aux chaudes pour sortir du bain
et non avec celle de la bmo
michel biche
vous prenez le bas après
de jeu mais le couvercle
beaucoup ignorent
si le sens du jeu ben il ne se trouve
pas à son terme et a précisé travers sur
son processus attaquants comme si la
toilette du corps qui est l'objet sont
tenus n'étaient finalement que
secondaire par rapport à toute une série
de plaisir qu'on se donne outre beaucoup
et un marge de ses ablutions
[Musique]
le monde d'aujourd'hui
oublieux du passé tout entier tourné
vers le plaisir produit par la
consommation des biens culturels
at il conservé malgré tout un passage
secret à cette source primitive de
bonheur
tu me donneras de des nouvelles d'un
chimiste et à qui la
caisse que le mange
un contrairement à l'exemple occidental
le bain aux japonais pas en u solitaire
il est si j'ose dire d'essence
collective
c'est un espace qui réunit d'abord les
membres de la famille dans une profonde
ainsi me taire je dirais un passant
qu'une telle conception
intimiste et familiale du bain semble
s'opposer très nettement à la conception
individualiste du bain occidental d'où
la caractérisation
érotique souvent attribués à ce lieu je
pense par exemple un très célèbre scène
de la douche dans psychose de hitchcock
l'eros entraîne le meurtre vous
connaissez ce film vous avez psychose
c'est terrifiant
[Musique]
dès mon arrivée un homme qu'on vit chez
callas elle assure des soins dits devant
toulouse une pratique ancestrale
d'actualité en finlande mais me dit il
toujours non reconnues par la médecine
[Musique]
la requête de
marc machin
[Musique]
la
structure
m
comme les autres
[Musique]
non mais
pour me collard s'est
passé ce matin à
4h20
le détournement des termes est une
spécialité de la slovaquie une fois par
mois les bains deviennent le théâtre de
spectacles des liens
hiver comme été sa santé ars se pressent
dans ces fêtes ce à quoi tic
ou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
je n'y étais pas
les dents
budaj
vous avez
longueur d'année
je les aime
les u15 dans les années 60 j'ai pas
pensé
je vais en valeur
donc impossible
il a fallu attendre tout avoir
certains des embauches me connecte à
votre gauche
jean
c'est de poser notre
jeu pour l'iphone
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vahirua
[Musique]
voilà
la capa ou
pas vous
[Musique]
là
la
meinau
oh
[Musique]
ce holding qamishli à tottenham des
jeunes ambrosetti mort en mai des pertes
ap londres la dernière ils n'étaient pas
atteints
d'un cancer est amusant et dure une
piétonne qui chérit crocs
et raffineurs nicosie lyon de
jean boudou budget mais elle dit
certains misaient
jusque dimanche qu'un visa au vent
israël est un mélodrame isabelle chaland
voilà sur le camping vers l'iss a laissé
notre serveur
pour le chantre ima
elle estime en garde - ne sera pas
un hasard nominativement des répondants
la troupe de jean michel
bravais trio tzane djamila les ailes de
la carlingue armani chanel john ligne
and data lié aux soins jean millaire
gamba monde pas comme il rame en bas
[Musique]
mais le hammam est aussi un grand fan
habitées selon certaines croyances par
des jeans des esprits malfaisants qui
apprécient la chaleur et l'obscurité
pour les éloigner il suffit d'invoquer
dieu et d'éviter le bain entre les deux
dernières prières de la journée
oh
[Musique]
e
il en va
toi
[Musique]
elles
pourront passer au monde
[Musique]
le mmd leur vie est dirigé depuis le
décès de son époux il ya un an madame
turc handball son mari avait géré ce
bain de quartier pendant plus d'une
cinquantaine d'années
[Musique]
s'est immolé
ce n'est qu'au fur des années
ouais
[Musique]
non
charles
bousculera pas ce que font ils à damas
mondiaux
[Musique]
86 et de dimanche et qui est un battant
victor and i'm sorry mieux c'est
pas du lait dans les champs selon le dr
dauzon
par contre
bien
[Musique]
acquerra me présente un couple d'amis
les a's acura
ils veulent me faire partager leur
plaisir nous dans un ryokan et l'auberge
traditionnel à quelques heures de tokyo
coût
bon
c'est trop
ce juriste
magna
gran torino thermique du bâti dans les
vins de ce monde flottant
c'est la traduction de l'expression clio
je crois ou quillot le monde flottant
les bains de ce monde flottant km
mélange
prêtre shinto east - ne bouddhiste
amoureux gens résignés de tous enfin
voila c'était au nom de savoir que
contrepoids dans le bain public au japon
il y avait sept cette espèce de
discussions littéraires philosophiques
parmi les baigneurs
aujourd'hui
c'est un îlot où une sorte de musée
vivant août s'est miraculeusement
conservé le passé quand j'ai écrit
ce texte c'était déjà une sorte de
souvenirs assez lointains parce que ça
fait vraiment longtemps que je ne
fréquente plus le symptôme
j'ai accompagné ma mère française
était en vie un rituel
[Musique]
c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
lointain
peut-être vous êtes
vous appartenez à une génération qui
ignorent totalement les ados parfois
je sais pas
parce que normalement la journée bien
cherché
à
cette eau
mon tour
donc en tant que document qui m'a star
[Musique]
des états unis
8 heures
bonjour
[Musique]
ok
m
[Rires]
duke a maté
n'avez vous donnez pas de chiffres
[Musique]
et
oh
elle
et
alors là
à cela
tél
comment
à
mr
[Rires]
[Musique]
lima et qui finit à l'image des
travaux
communautaires
en tout pour que france nous devons
maintenant tu t'entraînes en
a sûrement toyota tient dans la toyota
noire
pour l'intello unitaire c'est que les
collabos coûts totaux des causes qui nie
avoir été au camp nou ké ni le cigref
tout le monde sera vide
de nos gars là ok un mystère sur les
voilà à paris à 6,90 à nay en icône
année on s'oriente en gros ces jeunes
acteurs des volontairement
sous une autre qui est solide et des
gros qu'elle vous lis ou de langues à
mort sam lauthan
modern art est aussi surtout cette grève
de cristal à une cuisine à manille au
volant jusqu'à demander en quoi il
serait temps mais ouvrira le
traditionnel
[Musique]
dans l'ensemble du monde
mais il
[Musique]
non
ce
[Musique]
que je veux
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
et
vendredi
anouma vite chez son ami yahoo coûts à
venir prendre des sodas ce week-end dans
leur chalet à la campagne à quelque 300
km helsinki pour les femmes à voter je
sais que c'est un signe de grand honneur
que d'y être conviés
non
voilà
les oiseaux au
bon soin
ça va osama bin laden
brunel
il ya beaucoup de lois sont ici
[Musique]
on
7 heures du matin la soul aulas qui
rêverait d'organiser une grande soirée
dans la piscine découverte des mains du
tse toung
repérage avec son ami dj mango
les bulls avaient sonné
l'offre
dans la victoire
ateke majorque
[Musique]
pour l'autre oh
vers
20h30
ça m'était mail
[Musique]
c'est votre cause est
9e
amené l'accusé
mais bon
ça nous allons perdre une précieuse
le même pilote a woman show
[Musique]
cela gêne
je vois ça
l'antichambre
les chamans
[Musique]
i
on va
là
oh
or
m
zilina
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
4 1
jamais
[Musique]
the royal
ap ap
[Musique]
m
sauf moi
au fond
john a
obama
[Musique]
on aime bien
m
g
[Musique]
la demande
nos systèmes
ça va ça st
une
chinoise
la machine de tout et rien
guidolin tic des merveilles à paris
[Musique]
mme gillet comme le sous-sol en elle
nous avons du stadium et d'arrêter les
membres d'un improbable
[Musique]
grand dieu non
urnes
[Musique]
les parents de l'enfant
on en compte
jean
[Musique]
baptiste
hélas cette même carte à moi il ya les
deux parties le procureur il aime urbain
dans son arsenal
de l'armée des damnés les codages avancé
de commandes le coma
[Musique]
avant le retour à tokyo la famille
mizubayashi et leurs amis souhaitent
retrouver le sens finale du bpt un état
pur
cette fois dans un en scène une des
nombreuses sources thermales de la
région
pureté nature esthétique
trois notions fondamentales du bain
japonais
mais voilà
actuellement
de
l'humain sur
la ville et bastia 20e
yama lamanère
3000 mais surtout par
la manière masquée
je viens
vous allez la saison
allez
ats
mesdames
voir convaincante
non
malgré le vent
c'est un grand
terrain de jour
[Musique]
moore
dimanche en fin de week-end
après la pêche à nous nous rappelle
qu'il existe plus d'un million et donne
une semaine en finlande
cette pratique est en relation avec le
culte d'adoration du feu dans ce pays où
les mois sans lumière de l'hiver sont
interminables
il est un vieux proverbe qui dit de ce
lieu sacré au sonar conduite wacom à
l'église
les guildes le reggae
le guen
les partenaires
car on
peut s'amuser
le préposé
aux coups cox
m
[Applaudissements]
omar points à la tonnelle
mika le n l'homme et à
le hisser à la manade a évolué sur les
salaires
rens
m
c'était très beau lieu
le maire
[Musique]
m
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
akira à nous madame balle et la
slovaquie ces visages restent disséminés
dans la durée fluvial de ces images
multiplier à l'infini
et sont devenus à la fois familiers
lointain peut être un peu effacé au bout
de ce voyage
ce que je garde en moi c'est la pure
sensation de l'eau partout vivifiante et
accueillante
de cette eau qui soulage et guéri de
cette eau douce à la fois apaisante et
brillante
[Musique]